5 ans après avoir légalisé la
consommation de cannabis le Canada fait
face à une inquiétante augmentation des
hospitalisations pour épisodes
psychotiques c'est le résultat d'une
vaste étude publiée dans la revue
médicale j network Open qui s'est penché
sur les effets qu'aurait eu la loi
autorisant la commercialisation de
cannabis sur la consommation et la santé
mentale des Canadiens résultat en 2021
un/4 des Canadiens déclaré avoir
consommé du cannabis les 12 derniers
mois contre 10 % en France les
chercheurs de l'étude constatent une
brusque augmentation des
hospitalisations du au cannabis de plus
de 10 % en 2020 et 2021 dans les états
de l'Ontario de l'Alberta de Colombie
Britannique et du Québec plus inquiétant
encore ce sont les admissions pour
épisodes de psychos qui progresse le
plus soit quand la personne présente un
délire cela peut être dû non seulement à
une offre plus abondante et plus
accessible mais aussi au fait que les
produits ont maintenant des teneurs
beaucoup plus élevé en THC la substance
allucinogène du cannabis ce qui inquiète
car le risque de développer une
schizophrénie dans les 3 ans triple chez
ces personnes 40 % des jeunes hommes
âgés de 14 à 18 ans ont eu par la suite
des troubles schizophréniques entrée en
vigueur en octobre 2018 le cannabis Act
avait notamment pour but de limiter les
trafics et de protéger les jeunes le
Canada devenait alors le deuxième pays
au monde après l'Uruguay à mettre en
place une telle législation celle-ci a
donc permis d'éliminer partiellement les
trafics illégaux car les usagers
s'approvisionnent davantage à une source
légale et contrôlée par l'État par
contre l'objectif de protéger les
mineurs ne semble pas avoir été rempli
car la consommation au cours du dernier
mois pour les moins de 19 ans n'a pas
baissé depuis 2018 le cannabis Act lui
est en cours de révision mais nous
sommes car la situation peut s'aggraver
pour la santé publique si le marché
continue de se développer sans être
suffisamment
régulé